بمجرد أن أختار هذا القماش ،
أقوم برسمه ، أقوم بعمل نمط ، أقوم
بعمل الشاش من أجل
وضعه على أشكال الفستان
وإحيائه من هناك
نماذج مناسبة ، ثم هناك المدرج
عندما كنت في الثانية من عمري كنت أقف
بجانبه  مدفأة مع أختي البالغة من العمر ست سنوات
عندما انفجرت
لم تنجو من ذلك ، لقد ارتديت
نفسي ذلك
الصباح بمعطف فرو صغير وهذا هو السبب في
أنني كنت أحرق
وجهي ويدي اليسرى فقط
بترت وفقدت
أرقامًا جزئية في اليد اليمنى ،
أخبر الأطباء والدتي أنني
ربما لن أحظى بنوعية حياة جيدة ،
كان تشخيصهم خاطئًا بالتأكيد
، وسأأخذ قصاصات من
مشاريع خياطة أمي لصنع ملابس الدمى
وهكذا بدأت في ذلك  علمني أن أنقع
عندما كنت في الخامسة من عمري ،
فتحت صالة العرض الخاصة بي ومنزل الإنتاج
هنا في أركنساس في عام
2015. الرومانسية التي كتبها ليندا كتبت
مجموعة توماس المتخصصة في تصميم الأزياء المخصصة ،
وقد ظهرت تصاميمي على السجادة الحمراء
في Golden
أسبوع الموضة في جلوبز نيويورك وأكثر من ذلك بكثير ،
فإن اسم منظمتي غير الربحية هو تصميم
الأمل
الذي بدأ مع رغبتي في مساعدة
الناجين من الحروق
في هذه العملية ، أدركت أنه
ليست ندوب الجميع مرئية ،
وآمل أن يكون ضوء والدتي
أعطاني شخصًا آخر التشجيع
ليحقق أحلامه